welcome back to las vegas now two local
organizations are teaming up to help
everyone in the valley get proper
healthcare no matter who you are where
you're from
and here are their new town centers
around town
sarah from kano rachel from humana you
guys are working together to help our
community out let's talk about
the new center's opening up in las vegas
from keno
perfect yes so we're really excited
we've just opened
three clinics here in las vegas and
planning on branching out some more
really what we focus on is our medicare
patients and those that are underserved
in our community
so we want to make sure that we've
created a place where you can come
and feel supported by your clinical care
team where you want to come
and that you feel comfortable and
confident talking with your provider
that's great and i'm what does it mean
to have medicare focus with your centers
so for us medicare focus means that we
are holistic when we look at a patient
we don't want to just see you when you
feel
ill or you think there might be an issue
we really want to build that trust and
relationship with your pcp
so that when you see them that primary
care provider
that they know about you and your health
history and that it's a
teamwork conversation about how to get
you to your healthiest point in life
and make sure that you're living that
out so we want to make sure that we have
things like social workers
and people to help you in your wellness
center transportation to really help
make that robust system
that works around you as a patient and
works with each of the needs that you
have
awesome and rachel this next question is
for you that was actually the perfect
segue
um why is it important for people not to
skip out on their annual checkup
especially now since people are
a little more hesitant with going into
the doctor's office
exactly and that's why it's important to
focus on preventive proactive care and
not just aches and pains annual checkups
with your primary care provider may help
get to the root of any problem so it can
be taken care of
before it worsens or before you need to
go to the emergency room
we want our members to truly enjoy the
visits to the doctor and enjoy
compassionate care
that goes beyond the clinical that's why
we've added conno health to our network
i encourage you to learn more about them
our humana plans and the providers in
our network
awesome and sarah obviously this is
really important information for
medicare for people with medicare
what else should they know about the new
centers in town so we have a lot of new
services that are new to the las vegas
valley
and we also focus on a lot of different
areas that have been
in need and underserved here in las
vegas so we have a number of spanish
speaking and tagalog speaking providers
and staff members
so when you come in we treat you as a
whole person
that you can speak in your preferred
language we have an understanding of
some of your cultural background
and that you can build that trust with
the team as well as some of those things
that i mentioned
earlier with your transportation home
visits
making sure that we're in areas where
you're next to a grocery
store so if you come into our office you
can be empowered to do your grocery
shopping
when then get a ride home instead of
waiting for your adult child to take
time off of work
see you guys got everything covered for
us and i love that everyone gets the
chance to have the proper care so thank
you for that
for more information call 1-800-345-8017
or find them online at cannelhealth.com
or healththatcares.com kendall i'll send
it to you well there's